hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
today is
essentially part three of the four week
month long kind of
event thing going on of course if you're
not caught up to date year four season
two was delayed
so they're going to be giving us the
year three events on a weekly basis
the first week was the beginning of may
which was black prior
last week was the hitokiri event this
week is the yorman gunder event and next
week we'll end this month-long saga
with the zon who event as always we're
gonna go over what's in the event remake
first and then go over what's in the
original that didn't make it to the
remake so
as i was like to be if you're doing just
subscribe for new i cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the here
updates the patch notes and the leaks
if when we get to today with everything
happening in the world of foreigner and
never miss out on an update definitely
stay subscribe to the channel
and with that let's get started with
today's video but before we start that
there is an announcement of a new
tournament coming to for honor called
into the fray
it was talked about on ubisoft's twitter
account yesterday and it's going to be
happening every saturday for the next
three weeks starting on the 16th of may
it's across all platforms available to
anybody as long as they live in u.s
canada
mexico or europe and as long as they're
18 years or older they could participate
with a total prize pool of 9 000
those dates are may 16th may 23rd and
may 30th those are the three week
saturdays
the first place winner gets 225 because
this is going to be split
per platform per tournament so overall
though there is a good chunk of money to
be earned of this if you keep getting
those first place wins
and anybody can participate as long as
you sign up using the battlefield link
down below i'm not sure if there is a
set amount of spots for this tournament
so definitely keep that in mind and
hurry up as quick as possible to make
sure you have a spot if you have the
time to participate
but on to the main part of the video we
have the jorman gunder event
like i said we're gonna be talking about
what is in the remake or part two of
this and then what
was in the original but didn't make it
to the remake
so first up is the stuff in the remake
and that is the stuff that is
lootable which is the mood effect in the
idle execution and emote form
called hulda's wrath as always you don't
get all three versions together you have
to earn them separately so if you want
all three versions for the characters
you gotta get grinding the new battle
outfit store
champion for all factions is also
lootable it has this blue kind of color
scheme to it so it will fit with your
defender colors if you want to use this
obviously you could just get it for the
designs get it for the color totally up
to you usually i just get battle outfits
for the color scheme this is the same
for the ornament store medallion this is
also lootable and that meaning they're
all
rng and they are random you could play
one hero but get the effect for
another so definitely grind and hope you
get the effect ornament or battle outfit
that you need
next up is the two paid items being the
illustrious outfit which is 20 000
steel unless discounted is seeing as the
past two weeks they've had these things
discounted i'm just going to assume the
illustrious outfit is discounted so keep
that in mind
and this is also different depending on
the faction you get it for the
cila version is for the knights the
world serpent is the vikings
the sachi hoko is the samurai version
and the al quinn is the wulin version
of course like i said these are 20k
steel although i believe if it's
discounted it should be 13 000
and of course remember these are not
going anywhere anytime
soon as this has been in the game since
its release so you don't need to do this
within the week you can take your time
getting these
the one that is going to be here for the
week though that you will need to hurry
up and get if you want to get it
immediately is the execution the rampage
of ragnarok which is 10 000 steel
this utilizes the ragnarok hammer to
absolutely
launch the opponent into the sky that is
going to be 10 000 steel like i said
which should be discounted to i believe
seven or maybe 5 000 steel and yeah like
i said this is going to be a limited
time one so if you have to choose
between the execution or the mask outfit
i would probably pick the execution as
that's going away within the week
and you can get the illustrious or mask
outfit whenever you need to
later down the line lastly is the jorman
gunder event
weapons these are lootable but instead
of it being random like the effects and
ornaments if you use
warden you will get wardens weapons so
it matches the character you play just
like
normal without the event you know you
grind a game at the end of the game you
get the weapons you get the armor for
that specific hero
this is the exact same thing as always
since this is a remake in the
chronological timeline
zone who was not released at this moment
it was only up to yerma gunder so
zanhu cannot get anything for this event
he has no weapons no effects none of
this for this event you can still use
him to grind for the other
effect battle outfit and ornaments for
other heroes since those are completely
random
but if you're trying to grind for stuff
specific to that character you're not
going to be getting anything for him as
he has nothing for this event
now for what is not returning as this is
probably going to be a running theme
the main menu and the music for the
event is not going to return that is
still the current season year 4 season 1
hope as well as the minions are going to
be still the same as they usually are
those will not be changed
the game mode back then was actually a
nice twist on breach it was actually
breach 2.0 that we have currently
and on top of that it also had the
hammer of ragnarok this
isn't returning but for people who
didn't play it no worries as the game
mode is just pretty much a new game mode
with the ragnarok hammer in it called
carousel of ragnarok
you can still get the weapon like i said
but it's not in the original game mode
and of course a breach 2.0 like that
version of reach is the current breach
that we have so
not many things have changed they've
kind of split up and went on their own
path so to speak
carousel of ragnarok is fairly new as it
was debuted in
the honor games event just this season
so you've probably already played it
unless you're very very new
to the game for the people that haven't
played carousel of ragnarok it is a
twist on carousel of death
which is a 4v4 mode where one team has
to kill the other team at around the
same time
or they will respawn if you kill
everybody at the same time on the enemy
team
then the round is over and you win
carousel of ragnarok is the exact same
as that
except now the weapon in the middle of
the map is the ragnarok hammer
which can one shot anybody on the map so
be careful
this is going to be a pain and of course
because it's a carousel of death map it
is extremely tiny
and with that guys that's going to be
the end of today's video hope you guys
did enjoy like the video if you did
subscribe if you're new i cover the
informational side of foreigner that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patches and the leaks
if you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening in the world of
foreigner and never miss out on enough
they definitely stay subscribed to the
channel
alright guys take care have a great
today i'll see you on a couple days for
another new video
and i peace out goodbye
[Music]
you